harare habitants re bonsoir
on en parlait de françois hollande avec
bruno gaccio
en tant que professionnel de l'humour
vous le trouvez comment hollande ne
seriez un peu réservés il a des vannes
mais ils hésitent à les balancer alors
s'il enlever tout ce côté un peu
politique je pense vraiment ces rumeurs
et peut faire 6 mois à l'olympia elle
est très heureuse a pas très visuel
alors harry on connaît la légende à
métiers chauffeur de taxi pour payer vos
cours de théâtre vous savez que c'est
exactement comme ça que molière a
commencé sérieux sérieux alors à
l'époque donc vous avez 19 ans et vous
fait écouter vos sketches enregistrées
sur radio cassette à vos passagers en
leur faisant croire que ces régions sans
way complètement mais perd front et
georges essayé d'écouter un peu si
rigoler
et des facs dit pouvait baisser c'est
trop fort parce que le son était pourri
et des fois ça riez dfa salariés qui
restaient en france 2 les cinq francs et
puis un soir à sarcelles vous décidez de
vous auto produire et ça marche edit
marouane y est là qu est ce qui vous dit
il me dit vous valait 1 milliard
a été assigné lui il était imprésario de
marlène dietrich de dario moreno de 2,2
de jacques brel de tout ça mais voilà il
avait 80 ans et quand il m'a signé on a
fait le théâtre trévise et il est mort
six mois
voilà
[Applaudissements]
bon secours
alors après il y aura une première
partie des tricots macias et de gad
elmaleh le théâtre avec happy hanouka
panne pendant un an et le cinéma avec
coco de gad elmaleh fatale et ville la
france de michaël youn le problème
arrive c'est que plus vous donnez une
star plus vous parlez comme une star
j'ai lu un papier dans madame figaro
c'est épouvantable qu'est ce que j'ai
dit vous avez dit l'audace va de pair
avec l'amour de soi lorsque l'on réussit
quelque chose on s'aime davantage ou
l'avait piqué à nice france à n'avoir
jamais de ma vie j'ai dit ça c'est vrai
c'est dans ce journal non mais je sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire jeu mais
c'est pas possible j'ai pas pu dire une
flamme à y en a d'autres à revoir c'est
quoi
je ne suis pas nostalgique je me
concentre sur le présent aujourd'hui le
cinéma et la scène sont essentiels sans
virer du bruel amplement sous lexomil
sérieux j'ai dit c'est ouais alors là on
voit vous êtes vraiment devenu une star
c'est quand on vous voit au parc des
princes avec cécile de minibus ah oui
c'est formidable n'importe quoi le parc
des princes avec cécile de ménibus c'est
un rêve qui se réalise a ri mais pas du
tout c'est je suis au parc des princes
oui elle est assise à côté de moi aux
écoles on parle en vigueur et les photos
et puis voilà je me dis ah bon ben voila
et yamaha y avait un match oui
évidemment
des vins faut arrêter d'avoir été un bon
outil on change de faire une liste est
sûre avec des très drôle et rythmé oui
dites moi il ya une troisième photo
alors le ton qu'il ya sous la couverture
mais il n'y a rien du tout
elle a l'air triste mais voyant le mec
la notaire merci donc à droite de
l'empathie c'est le mec à côté qui fait
les
benjamines mémoire et habitants il est
en tournée dans toute la france avec son
one man show qui s'appelle à la folie à
la folie
et voilà on passe maintenant l'actualité
la semaine avec lui vitaux de byakko et
c'est christine kelly membre du csa et
créatrice de la fondation k d'urgences
que nous retrouverons sur ce plateau
après le magnéto
[Musique]
je tue vapeur
je fais désormais inscrit dans la loi
les enfants n'ont pas besoin d'une maman
pour être heureux alors puisque de nos
jours les papas peuvent faire tu
excellente maman pourquoi leur confie
son psy peu la garde des enfants en cas
de divorce
selon les chiffres du ministère de la
justice la mère obtient la garde des
enfants dans plus de 75% des cas
pourtant en 2002 ségolène royal a fait
voter une loi pour promouvoir la garde
alternée c'est important que le père et
la mère garde ce devoir d'autorité et
d'affection et d'éducation et garde son
enfant dé 10 ans plus tard cette
solution est appliquée que dans 15% des
divorces faut dire qu'en cas de
séparation quand papa et maman se
disputent la garde des enfants les juges
donnent souvent raison à maman comme si
les magistrats avaient conservé une
vision de la famille à l'ancienne papa
travaille dur pour gagner des sous du
coup ils rentrent tard le soir et passe
peu de temps avec ses enfants raconte
trois sait comment l'école aujourd'hui
alors en cas de divorce peu importe que
papa ne voit plus ses enfants que quatre
jours par mois le principal c'est qu'il
faille la pension alimentaire
pourtant la société évoluée aujourd'hui
80 % des pères assisté à l'accouchement
70 % prennent un congé paternité et puis
les pubs sont remplies de papa poule qui
change les couches donne le bain se
répare les bombes sigla alors puisque
les papas sont devenues de vraies
petites mamans pourquoi cette île privée
de la garde de leurs enfants en italie
ces différentes depuis 2006 la garde
alternée est devenu la solution
prioritaire en cas de divorce quand un
juge refuse la garde alternée il doit
expliquer pourquoi résultat 40 % des
enfants de couples divorcés partagent
leur vie à temps égal entre papa et
maman en france de plus en plus de pères
semblent prêts à se battre pour
s'occuper de leurs enfants après un
divorce en revanche quand il s'agit de
s'occuper des enfants avant le divorce
là c'est autre chose selon l'insee dans
une famille avec deux enfants
80% des tâches domestiques sont assurés
par la mer
c'étaient les vitres de blacko mise en
image de juin pas question qu'ils m'ont
soir
sa
créatrice de la fondation k d'urgences
et nous publié en mars chez léo cher le
scandale du silence consacrée au sort
des familles monoparentales
bienvenue parmi nous
vous est ce que le sien ça je le sais ça
accepte ça que monsieur fumant plateau
sais pas je ne fume pas
la cigarette est interdite effectivement
à la télévision c'est interdit de fumer
mais je viens d'être saisie pour qu'on
puisse me demander
2 d'interdire les cigarettes
électroniques pourquoi la télévision ben
il me faudra me pencher dessus et c'est
bon pas déjà pour le moment c'est pas
vrai donc je ne sais pas pour maintenant
il ya peut-être un vide juridique faut
que je me calme sinon vous pouvez y
aller c'est bien pour nous j'ai encore
été engagé comme je ferme les yeux mais
je vais regarder mais les yeux pour voir
et super g des finales au parc des
princes
peut-il obtenir la garde de son fils il
n'a pas de grue à proximité c'était la
question de la semaine lors d'un divorce
la mère garde les enfants dans 75 % des
cas et 84% quand il s'agit de couples
non mariés
dans ce cas le père a droit en droit de
visite classique c'est-à-dire un
week-end sur deux et vacances scolaires
mais aujourd'hui les pères ont changé
ils veulent la garde alternée c'est à
dire une semaine sur deux et c'est vrai
comme du blaco si deux mecs peuvent
élever un enfant pourquoi un père ne
pourrait pas l'être à mi temps c'est
toute la question alors si de pair oui
mais là après c'est ça si deux paires
ont un enfant il faudra installer des
grues dans toute la france voilà
qui va rester c'est dommage parce qu'il
faut regarder vraiment si le papa peut
vraiment élever l'enfant et a souri on
ne se pose pas la question et c'est un
peu scandaleux de ne pas se poser la
question le père bien dans bien des cas
peut-être pas toujours mais bien des cas
il peut élever son enfant donc il faut
vraiment ces nouveaux pères enfin appelé
papa peut aujourd'hui quoi oui tout à
fait il n'y a pas de pension alimentaire
mondiale garde alternée 6 6 à 10
novembre et moi j'ai fait deux fois j'ai
deux séparations et le dernier on s'est
séparé il avait un an et demi donc j'ai
élevé un enfant en bas âge donc j'ai
fais pas alterner tout ça c'est bien
passé ça s'est très bien passé un an ils
sont encore très jeune quand même moi je
pense que oui mais ces jeunes maintenant
il faut la laisser à la mer vraiment là
il parle comme les justes
moi je sais pas dans ma culture en tout
cas évidemment c'est la maman qui essaie
pourtant de ta culture parce qu'il se
trouve que les hommes ne demande pas la
garde parce que bien content très
content de la mère s'occupe des gosses
bruno il ya aussi des mamans qui sont
contentes confiait la garde alternée de
redevenir célibataire une semaine sur
deux
évidemment parce qu'à un moment donné le
divorce va devenir un luxe pour cette
femme pour le closer non mais le droit
pourrait pourrait changer c'est vrai il
ya des propositions de loi enfin tout ça
c'est des sujets compliqués parce que ça
ça prend en compte des cas individuels
donc c'est difficile de dire globalement
alors qu'il ya autant de cas individuels
comme en mai au moins essayons de
raisonner ce serait que la garde
alternée voilà la règle est que
l'exception sur des cas de figure parce
que le père n'est pas parce que la
merveille aussi parce qu'ils sont très
très éloignées qu'on va pas faire
voyager des enfants de l'essence pendant
bon il ya plein de raisons qui font que
ça ne pourrait ne pas l'être mais que la
règle soit la garde alternée parce que
cet enfant il était fait à deux parce
que l'est la bourse est partagée sur
sept enfants alors pour le moment il ya
15% de garde alternée mais c'est une
tendance y en a de plus en plus tous les
ans bruno une question vous avez
beaucoup milité pour le mariage pour
tous en cas de divorce entre deux hommes
qui gardent l'enfant ne le papa maman
alors il faudrait dans l'intimité de ces
couples pour savoir celui qui est plus
actif ou passif le plus souvent tout ça
pour savoir alors on en arrive au
problème évidemment les pédopsy ils
disent qu'en cas de garde alternée il ya
un manque un manque de figure
d'attachement à la mer
manquent de repères stables voilà en
même temps dans quelqu'un il n'y a pas
de manque je veux dire aucun cas n'est
vraiment sans pression de l'eau s'ils
sont pas d'accord oui les pédopsy sont
pas d'accord non plus lorsqu'un enfant
est dans un couple qui se déchire les
pédopsy sont pas d'accord non plus
lorsque il est qu'avec la maman les
pédopsychiatres quand ils sont qu'avec
le papa dans quelqu'un un pédophile est
d'accord d'accord mais ce n'est pas
l'objet il faut interroger c'est le jaf
s'est vu d'autres familiale parce que
c'est quand même lui qui décide c'est ce
juge aux affaires familiales il est il
est aussi tête papa ou les mamans ils
souhaitent expérience d'affaires
familiales il a quinze cas à régler tous
les matins ils en font plus les
surcharger mais oui mais c'est lui qui
décide de l'avenir d'un enfant ouais
quand même lui qui pense qu'il mesure là
le jour la gravité de sa tête mais j'ai
rencontré plusieurs cas où des couples
sont d'accord le père hanna sont
d'accord pour la garde alternée et le
juge aux affaires familiales n'accorde
pas la garde alternée donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un vrai effort à faire à ce
niveau là au niveau de la justice vous
savez ce qu'il faut promouvoir en
premier c'est le divorce pourquoi pour
l'enfant dont les parents au lieu un
problème et qui décide de ne plus vivre
ensemble ça peut être un plus mais
l'enfant voit les familles se
recomposent l'enfant voit un couple d'un
côté mais il sait que de l'autre côté il
ya le papa et la maman chacun a une
façon de vivre pour prendre mon cas
puisque c'est que des cas personnel mes
enfants à moi les deux garçons font la
cuisine font le ménage font la vaisselle
mais c'est bien à quel âge ils ont 16
ils ont commencé très jeune parce que
j'y vois pas pas le faire papa fait la
cuisine papa fait de ménages feu quand
ils sont là et donc ils font ce qu'ils
voient et je pense que quand ils sauront
mari il ne reproduiront pas l'éternel
cliché qui est 80% des gonzesses qui
font le ménage moi j'ai refait de
dieu je suis macho mais je suis d'accord
les démagos que je viens dire qu'on fera
applaudir
divorce dans les couples séparation des
activités bancaires visa demandé partage
oui
il ya un autre truc quand même qui se
profile à l'horizon c'est le
masculinisme qui est une espèce d'anti
féminisme très violente avec un retour
de la suprématie masculine
parce que des mecs qui monte sur des
grues en france mais au québec en
angleterre et des mecs qui monte sur des
ponts c'est pas un truc nouveau nom
crois que c'est nouveau c'est pas
nouveau et donc ces mecs là sont des
masculinistes
mais moi je pense qu'il faut demander
l'avis aux femmes parce que je pense que
les femmes veulent des hommes à elles
veulent des hommes
[Applaudissements]
pas des mecs qui font la vaisselle tabac
beaucoup d'albums
non mais je pense qu'une femme elle veut
un homme complet qui s'occupe des
enfants qui s'occupe de sa femme qui
fait la cuisine de temps en temps et
qu'ils lui fassent l'amour comme il faut
c'est ce que veut une femme qui lui
fasse l'amour
je vais
alors là
durant 20 ans
alors ces mecs là donc les masculinistes
eux ils voudraient que la loi prenne en
compte le syndrome d'aliénation
parentale or qu'est-ce que c'est le s ap
c'est quand les mères disent aux enfants
ton père est un con
ah oui une fois qu'il ya eu un divorce
la mère elle dit aux enfants ce connard
wii party avec une ordure machin tout
bon est
ce qu'ils voudraient les masculinistes
c'est que les zones 10 ta mère est une
colle
spéciale dans tous les cas c'est pas
bien je le dis dans mon livre le
scandale du silence que
jeudi qu'ils allaient papa poule et
allez papa coque ceux qui partent et qui
abandonnent entre guillemets leurs
familles mais il ya aussi la femme qui
empêche au père de voir l'enfant et ou
bien qui justement des grains de l'image
du père pour l'enfant le problème c'est
que un enfant milieu et n'a pas demandé
à être là et je pense que pour l'enfant
il ne faut pas dégrader effectivement
l'image du père il faut toujours garder
en famille monoparentale le contact avec
le père et sans dégrader son image ils
sortent en vocal roma
oui
erik arnaud pour conclure mais derrière
tout ça il ya beaucoup de drames humains
il ya beaucoup de souffrances on le voit
bien et donc là tout doit reposer sur
l'intelligence et le consensus donc la
garde alternée devrait devenir la norme
il me semble et nouveau centre situation
difficile et compliqué mais il me semble
que ce serait notre ère par cas parce
qu'il ya la norme sauf si sauf si il
faut bien qu'il est normal sauf si la
paire une mère 50% sauf si c'est bon ce
truc là
c'est comme une chicha portative quoi
pour l'instant c'est moins dangereux
évidemment que le tabac n'y a pas de
goudron il n'ya pas d'arsenic et toutes
les saloperies comment le tabac mais
dont trente ans on va nous dire il ya un
truc de dents qui va tuer mon pote
fautes mais je ne peux plus ouais c'est
ce qu'on nous a dit pour l'essayer bon
ben si j'avais analysé de près si d'ici
là il franchement je vais peut-être
regretter d'appareiller bruno si je ne
sais même pas fumer et
ribéry
sur le bouton tu tires comme ça tire la
fumée qui sort
elle sans rien
émission du matin grand barbu
destine merci d'avoir été avec 0 merci
beaucoup pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu